what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar and with the recent few shocking
chapters in wano dealing with green bull
i realized that it's about time to
update my marine admirals video since we
have a lot more information out
especially about greenville if you
enjoyed seeing one piece videos like
this one and want to keep them coming
channel the parking within and smash
that like button always be a smashing
power king rather than a passing orochi
and you will be greeted with youtube
fireworks if you haven't joined the
nakama by subscribing and hitting that
notification bell so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all the rank of admiral is
the second highest rank in the marines
there are only three admirals at a time
above them is the fleet admiral the
highest marine rank although the fleet
admiral commands the entire organization
he is still ranked below the world
government commander-in-chief the five
elders and now as we found out
relatively recently the mysterious
imusama the admirals are known as the
world government's greatest military
powers since each of them is extremely
strong admirals similar to the fleet
admiral can issue buster calls on
islands that are deemed to be threats
let's start off with the 55 year old
akainu aka sakazuki who is over 10 feet
tall by the way before he was a fleet
admiral he used to be an admiral and at
that time he went by the alias akainu
which means red dog however now that
he's fleet admiral he goes by sakazuki
when former fleet admiral sengoku
stepped down he wanted aokiji to take
the job but dignitaries within the
government pushed for sakazuki the two
meaning aokiji and sakazuki fought a
one-on-one duel the winner would seize
the right to command the marines they
were evenly matched for 10 whole days
before sakazuki emerged victorious
aokiji then left the marines apparently
not wanting to work for a kainu akainu
was the most ruthless of all the
admirals which is probably why sengoku
favored aokiji akainu is thorough in
trying to stamp out whatever or whoever
he deems to be evil or a threat to
absolute justice as a result he killed
ace and badly scarred luffy akainu would
even rather sacrifice innocent lives
than let one guilty person get away
which was shown when he destroyed a
refugee ship because one rule-breaking
scholar might have made it on board in
contrast aokiji said he would never go
as far as that and call the kainu a jerk
akainu was even willing to kill kobe a
marine just because he wanted the battle
at marine 4 to end he's and ends justify
the means kind of guy and he will do
anything to bring about a world of
absolute justice akainu is even willing
to talk back to the elders when they get
in the way of his vision which is pretty
impressive during chapter 595 even the
powerful blackbeard decides to run away
from a kainu stating that he's not ready
for that battle yet even though he has
whitebeard's devil fruit at this point
and some of the world's worst criminals
on his crew akainu possesses the
magumagu no me aka magmag fruit this
logia devil fruit lets him create
manipulate and become magma a kai news
devil fruit appeared to be of a higher
order than aces it's been said that
because of magma's unique properties and
its higher temperature akainu's attack
injures ace despite his logia defenses
at the same time in my previous video it
was commented that fire can actually
reach a higher temperature than magma
even if magma is hotter than your
average fire this raises the exciting
potential of sabo being able to bring
out more of the flame fruit's potential
and get revenge for ace although
honestly for me it's hard to see such a
big opponent being beaten by sabo
especially after he scarred luffy i've
also heard theories that magma absorbs
fire and that's why akainu could
penetrate ace and some people just say
he used haki but let me know your
favorite interpretation in the comments
anyways akainu's logia powers are so
strong that he was able to permanently
change the climate of punk hazard a
kainu can use armament haki and
observation hockey and in fact all
marines ranked vice admiral and up can
use haki it has not been confirmed that
akainu has conquerors haki but i'd be
surprised if he doesn't given his power
and important leader status in fact oda
said that akainu is so strong that he
could end the one-piece series within a
year if you were the protagonist and he
said that back in 2012 given the recent
importance placed on haki and especially
on conquerors haki and how it's way more
important than fruit powers it seems
pretty obvious to me that akainu has it
even if it hasn't been confirmed yet all
in all this dude is definitely a worthy
antagonist for luffy given his power and
history with our protagonist and since
gear 5 luffy was recently able to use
advanced conquerors haki to punch magma
dragon kaido without making physical
contact and thus without melting his arm
he might be ready to take on akainu too
let me know your thoughts on that match
up below and if luffy is ready to take
him on next let's look at the currently
49 year old kuzon aka aokiji before
kuzon gave up being an admiral he went
by aokiji which means blue pheasant
after he lost his fight against the
kainu kuzon left the marines and
according to the elders he's been
helping blackbeard this is a very
curious turn on the one hand it makes
blackbeard who was already extremely op
seem even stronger on the other hand
kuzon could be a spy it is weird that a
kainu let him survive their battle so it
could be that they set it up so that
kuzon would help the marines by keeping
a close eye on blackbeard we'll see what
ends up happening but it definitely
seems strange that the sengoku
recommended kuzon would join forces with
blackbeard especially since kuzon seemed
like the nicest guy out of the former
three admirals kuzan is nine foot nine
inches tall so he's a bit shorter than a
kainu but definitely nothing to complain
about and he's way more laid back than
akainu practicing his own form of lazy
justice rather than absolute justice
however more accurately he has his own
moral compass and follows moral justice
unlike a kainu he's compassionate he's
willing to help a child rob and escape a
buster call and he is willing to not
arrest the young luffy after he helps
people by defeating crocodile unlike
akainu kuzon wouldn't want to sacrifice
a number of innocent lives just to get
rid of one guilty person kuzon is no
doubt very powerful otherwise sengoku
would not have recommended him for fleet
admiral and he would not have lasted 10
days fighting against the extremely
powerful akainu when a fight drags on
for that long you start to think that it
might have gone either way if conditions
were only slightly different akainu is
even six years older so it's at least
possible that kuzn could become stronger
down the line it's also noteworthy that
most marine troops preferred kuzon and
supported him showing that kuzon is a
good leader who has the ability to
positively influence others this ability
to lead also hints at the fact that he
could be a conker's hockey user as well
he's powerful enough to easily scare off
someone as powerful as doflamingo he was
able to battle with whitebeard until
diamond jozu one of whitebeard's
commanders entered the fray allowing
whitebeard to move on kuza took
advantage of a distraction eventually
took jozu down without much trouble so
as we've seen he can clearly fight with
the best of them now let's look at his
devil fruit powers he ate the hinomi aka
the ice ice fruit this slogi of fruit
lets him create manipulate and become
ice he can easily freeze miles of ocean
and even giant tsunamis he can freeze
his enemies and then easily shatter
their bodies kuzon's logia powers like a
kain news are strong enough to
permanently change the climate of an
area as we saw with punk hazard what's
especially cool about kuzon yes pun
intended is that he can avoid the most
common threat of devil fruit users by
freezing the sea water below him thus if
he's ever in a position where he's about
to fall in and drown he can just freeze
the water below him he regularly uses
his freezing powers to travel across the
sea and the fact that he just bikes over
the sea makes him all the more awesome
not to mention hilarious what is perhaps
the most impressive thing about kusan's
power is how he is able to survive
hockey imbued attacks like they were
nothing for instance when whitebeard
stabbed through him with his haki imbued
weapon kuzon was able to come out of it
fine that's a whole other level of logia
mastery right there it appears like
kuzon was able to make a hole in his
body before the weapon penetrated him
and thus avoided the damage kuzon also
possesses observation haki and armament
haki and if my rational speculation
about akainu is correct it's almost
certain that kuzon who fought him for 10
days is also an unconfirmed conker's
hockey user if luffy agrees to let
yamato join the straw hats then there
are already three conquerors hockey
users on the straw hat crew alone namely
yamato zorro and luffy so it wouldn't
even be surprising if all admirals had
conquerors haki since the marines are a
much bigger organization and the straw
hats despite being much smaller already
have three users haki aside kuzon can
form sharp weapons out of his ice and
use them to attack his opponents all in
all kuzon is more than a force to be
reckoned with and if blackbeard truly
acquired the former admiral's loyalty
that's an insane addition to the
blackbeard pirates next let's look at
the currently 58 year old borsolino aka
kizuru his admiral alias means yellow
monkey the constantly grinning kizaru is
the only remaining admiral from the
pre-time skip trio since akainu was
promoted to fleet admiral and kuzon
resigned kisar was also tall at 9 foot
11 inches these three admirals towered
over most people in height and strength
borcelino is the oldest and that's also
reflected by the wrinkles on his face
his form of justice is explained by oda
to be unclear justice he's not as moral
as kuzon but he's also not as much of an
extremist as a kainu and wouldn't take
as much initiative as he does kizuru
prefers to follow orders rather than
lead in regards to combat he's among the
best he's extremely fast his logia lets
him attack and move at the speed of
light he clashed against legends like
silver's rayleigh and whitebeard and
came out fine he also eventually
attacked luffy after shanks's first mate
ben beckman threatened him and even
offered to go to wana when he found out
that big mom and kaido formed an
alliance think about how crazy that is
for a second kaido and big mom were the
two living yonko with the highest
bounties together they had a bounty
around 9 billion berries to put this in
perspective the pirate king gold d roger
had a bounty of around five and a half
billion berries and kizuru offers to go
to wano even akainu is like chill bro so
it's quite clear that kizoru is not only
extremely strong but practically
fearless now let's look at his devil
fruit power the pika pika nomi aka
glinklin fruit it allows kizuru to
create control and become light he can
shoot laser beams create lightsabers to
fight with and turn parts of his body
into light and then hit his opponents
with the force of light speed not only
can he travel at the speed of light he
can also use mirrors or reflective
surfaces to propel him so that he can
get to any point he wishes to almost
instantaneously as if he were
teleporting kizaru is also skilled at
using observation hockey and armament
hockey if i had to pick someone who's
least likely to have conquerors haki out
of the first three admirals it's kizaru
but still like i said i wouldn't be
surprised if all admirals had conquerors
hockey before we jump to the new
admirals let's look at the now 79 year
old sengoku the buddha before he was
fleet admiral he too was an admiral he's
one of the ogs along with garp
whitebeard goldie roger captain rocks
and so on sengoku was one of the marines
that goldie roger respected the other
being garp at the battle of marineford
he is able to restrain garp and send all
of the skilled blackbeard pirates flying
backwards with one of his attacks he's
no longer in his prime but he's clearly
still one of the strongest characters in
the series he possesses the hitohito no
me model daibutsu aka the human human
fruit model buddha this is a mythical
zone fruit a class rarer than logia type
fruits this fruit allows its user to
transform into a large golden buddha his
strength is magnified in this form
giving his blows immense destructive
power he can also release powerful shock
waves in this form and it can be assumed
that he has one of the best defenses
when he's transformed sengoku unlike the
other skilled admirals on this list is
confirmed to be able to use all three
types of hockey including the rare
conquerors haki next we have one of the
new admirals the 54 year old isho known
also by his alias fujitora which means
wisteria tiger he's shorter than all the
previously mentioned admirals at 8 feet
10 inches tall but i'm sure for most of
us it's still pretty tall like who's on
fujitora is against the extremist view
of absolute justice as opposed to a
kainu who is willing to sacrifice the
innocent fujitora prioritizes protecting
people he is blind and says that he
earned his lack of sight by his own
actions and that he shut his eyelids on
his own after he saw too many things he
didn't care for however after an
encounter with luffy fujitora supposes
that he shouldn't have closed his eyes
because he wants to take a look at
luffy's face to see how such an honest
guy looks in front of the world fujitora
apologizes to the proper king of
dressrosa riku after doflamingo is
defeated and says that it was through
the actions of pirates gladiators and
citizens that the country seized victory
this is practically a kainu's worst
nightmare and fujitora even chooses not
to apologize to a kainu after doing it
fujitora an admiral admits in the open
that the marines can do the wrong thing
and make mistakes while pirates can do
the right thing and protect the innocent
you can't help but like the guy who's
willing to follow his own moral compass
no matter what his superior the fleet
admiral will think fujitora is strong
enough to easily block attacks from
former warlord doflamingo and luffy
during dressrosa couldn't do much to him
either except leave a positive
impression he could also clash with sabo
the number two ranked member of the
revolutionaries and an extremely skilled
fighter for an extended period of time
without taking any significant damage
now let's get into fujitora's devil
fruit the paramecia type zushizushi no
me this fruit gives him gravity powers
that he uses in conjunction with his
sword he can create gravitational forces
that move horizontally or vertically he
can use downward gravity to trap an
opponent in place or he can use
gravitational force to repel people and
things away from himself he can even
pull down meteorites from space madras
style even someone as skilled and
experienced as doflamingo couldn't
believe that this dude was bringing
actual meteorite down to earth fujitora
is also skilled at observation armament
haki furthermore he's been seeing
imbuing his sword with haki his
observation hockey is what lets him
fight effectively without vision he's so
good that he can even sense people's
emotions and thoughts not just their
fast physical movements and finally
we're here the last admiral we have to
cover is ryokugyu aka aramaki the second
new admiral his alias means green bull
this is the admiral that we knew by far
the least about when i made the previous
version of this video up to that point
we just knew that his silhouette was
seen smiling and joking around with
fujitora even while akainu was mad at
the latter we knew greenball had long
wavy hair and wore a marine coat we also
knew he hadn't had a bite to eat for
three years but he did reveal his love
of pretty ladies we knew that he was
strong enough to clash along with fellow
admiral fujitora with the formidable
captains of the revolutionary army no
small feat especially for a man running
on an empty stomach doflamingo has said
that there are rumors that both of the
new marine admirals are powerful
monsters so it's quite possible that
green bull is on par or maybe even
stronger than fujitora and if i had to
bet i'd say he is stronger and that's
why he was saying for last as with all
of the other admirals he knows
observation armament haki in the last
version of the video i hyped up
greenville because as mentioned oda kept
him for last shrouded in mystery which
is usually what shonen authors do for
the stronger characters and after
reading the recent chapters of the manga
i must say oda did not disappoint there
were a lot of theories floating around
about green bull including that he had a
plant-based through power and that he
was actually zoro's father one of these
theories has already been confirmed kind
of the reasons i thought he might have a
plant-based power was because of the
green in his name and also the fact that
he didn't eat which suggested to me that
he might get his nutrients from
photosynthesis when he appeared in
chapter 1052 it looked good for this
theory since he was seen flying around
with a kind of flower helicopter
sticking out from his back gotta hand to
the admirals they definitely have
uniquely awesome ways of traveling at
this point sakazuki aka kainu is asking
him where he is through his snail phone
and green bull says in the air as if
that helps narrow it down it's moments
like this that seem to support the idea
of him being zorro's dad since zoro is
legendary for his lack of direction
sense as well anyways greenball finally
spots wano up ahead and sakazuki tells
him don't you dare make things any worse
and greenball simply says i know i know
g's then we head to the following
chapter where we see his strength level
face and fruit abilities at work
although his powers still look related
to plants his nutrient gaining process
is much more deadly than photosynthesis
we see him launching roots all over the
place that penetrate the former beast
pirates and he sucks nutrients from them
that way in turn the victims begin to
look dried up and old so i guess a
fujitora is similar to madara with his
meteor dropping powers green bull is
sort of similar to hashirama with his
wood style powers the craziest part is
that even king and queen two yonko
commanders with bounties of 1.32 billion
and 1.39 billion respectively are easily
dealt with now yes they were heard
during the fight and king is even shown
with bandages but still it's been a week
and luffy and zoro seem fine now so it's
still very impressive what green ball
was able to do furthermore despite the
fact that they were the strongest
commanders of the so-called strongest
creature in the world and the yonko with
the highest bounty greenville comments
that a guy in his position can't go
around getting beat by pirate
subordinates thus even if they were in
tip-top shape the implication is that
green bull would still crush them and
it's a big deal because we saw how ben
beckman spoke with admiral kizuru at the
paramount war and the respect he gave
him ben commanded him not to do anything
and at first at least kizuru put his
hands up and said oops you're ben
beckman clearly showing a lot more
respect to the aqua commander than green
bull showed queen and king yes it's
likely in part because ben beckman is
stronger than king and queen but it
still could be read as greenville being
very strong even for an admiral and this
is also an interesting moment because
green bull with his actions and words
seems to confirm that most of the time
admirals are stronger than yanko
commanders perhaps not a shocking
revelation but interesting nonetheless
and it makes sense since if there are
usually three admirals at a time while
there are four yonko it would be weird
for the admirals to be struggling with
every yonko commander that being said it
does appear like marco and especially
ben beckman stand out as being pretty
special let me know right now in the
comments where would you rank greenville
in power compared to the other admirals
we've seen like kizaru fujitora and so
on i'd love to see how you guys rank the
admirals after these latest chapters
back to the chapter at hand though and
we even see green bull drinking beer
through his roots another potential clue
to him being zoro's father after
sakazuki told him not to cause any
trouble he does the complete opposite
and calls for a battleship to be sent to
him and even tells the listener not to
squeal to sakazuki so this dude is
acting on his own right now he says he
loves sakazuki's cut no corners attitude
and he says he wants to hear sakazuki's
praise when green bull brings him
luffy's head so just the fact that he
thinks he can take down everyone that
just brought down kaido and big mom also
speaks volumes about his confidence and
potential strength i personally don't
see him being a real threat to gear 5
luffy and his allied forces but it does
depend at least in part on how recovered
exactly our guys are to say the least it
should be interesting to see green bull
crash the party and i can't wait to see
what happens next now even though
aramaki's fruit hasn't been named yet it
is clearly related to plants in one way
or another however rather than just
being a vague plant logia or something
it could very well be something more
hype like a mythical zone model juboko
based on a japanese tree yokai that
thirsts for human blood since no admiral
except the legendary former fleet
admiral sengoku has had a mythical zone
so far and since it is the most rare and
hype category of fruit that would serve
to further distinguish green bull among
the already impressive admiral class if
you want to learn more about aramaki's
potential fruit and the juboco myth
definitely check out our why everyone is
afraid of admiral green bull video link
in the description but that's it for
today's video all six known admirals and
what we know about them so far and their
powers if you enjoyed this video make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know remember always be a smashing power
king rather than passing orochi and you
will be rewarded with youtube fireworks
if you haven't make this the video you
joined the nakama by subscribing and
hitting that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one-piece videos and updates and
we all know this is definitely not the
time to be missing one piece let me know
what type of one piece video you would
like to see next in the comments and
while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my big and
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos on all the yonko warlords
supernova mythical zone fruits and much
more link to that is in the description
and on screen right now and until next
time see ya space cowboys